on this week's episode of The Bachelor
the group headed to Sin City where the
girls put on a talent show for Ben Emily
and Haley did an Irish jig Jubilee
played the cello but Olivia's talent
takes the cake literally shortly after
her performance the 23 year old news
anchor had a full-blown meltdown there
sorry a panic attack I don't want to be
on camera why can't it just have a
moment I don't have talent yeah so I
tried to do something way outside my
comfort zone but didn't go that well all
right like I couldn't even look at him
because I knew he was mortified it's
just embarrassing
like I'm here to be like marriage
material and I don't think I scream like
marriage material later
Olivia pulled Ben aside and tried to
explain the whole ordeal I did something
that I would have never done in a
million years and I was super
embarrassed about it
Olivia wound up scoring the final rose
of the evening while Rachel amber and
Haley were eliminated next week the
group travels to Mexico City and the
Olivia drama is far from over
I'm surprised he's falling for
commandeth she does have children's feel
like it's an episode of tea
Olivia is a [ __ ] that is the most
offensive thing in the world